this creature was crowned the world's
ugliest animal in 2013
a title it still defends today on land
he's got a body like jello and a big old
frown
but drop this fellow 9 200 feet below
sea level
and the water holds up all that flab
like a push-up bra
making the fish a little more handsome
same old fish
but with a little more support so what
is all that water pressure holding
together
between the skin the flabby skin
and the muscles is a lot of fluid
this is david stein a deep sea fish
biologist who was lucky enough to
dissect
19 blob fishes in the 1970s blobfish
look
blobby because they are full of water
under their skin
blobfish have a thick layer of
gelatinous flesh
that floats outside their muscles if you
pick up a blobfish by the tail
then it kind of flows
to the head this water-filled
jell-o-like layer allows the blobfish to
stay somewhat buoyant
which is important because blobfishes
don't have a swim bladder
and fishes that have swim bladders are
able to
adjust their buoyancy they can secrete
gas
into the swim bladder or remove it
a fish that lives on the bottom doesn't
need to be able to maintain its buoyancy
so the jello layer isn't a perfect
substitute but the blobfish doesn't need
to be a strong swimmer
the predator has a highly specialized
hunting strategy that's perfect for the
rocky barrens of the deep sea
just sits there and waits for dinner to
come by if all you do is sit
you don't need much under your skin just
watery tissues some yellow pockets of
fat and a smidgen of muscle
in case you hadn't guessed blobfishes
aren't exactly yoked
they have very little red muscle the
kind that allows you
a human to run a mile or a tuna fish to
migrate across oceans
instead blobfish have a lot of white
muscle which allows them to swim in
short bursts and lunge at prey that on
occasion
ramble by this is a baby blobfish
it's a cleared and stained specimen
meaning all its tissue has been
dissolved to show only the bones and
cartilage
those thin red lines you see they're the
blobfish's bones
dyed red if you're having trouble seeing
the bones you're not the only
one blobfish have poorly ossified
skeletons meaning they're thinner and
more fragile than the bones of most
shallow water fish
this is another handy deep sea
adaptation as it takes a lot of precious
energy to build strong bones
but the blobfish saves its energy to
develop what might be the most important
bone in its body
its jaws which also happen to be the
reason it looks so gloomy
the fish needs enormous jaws so it can
snap up any prey that passes by and
swallow it whole
maybe even smacking its blubbery lips as
it eats
and that brings us to its stomach if
you're the kind of creature that eats
anything that swims by
some surprising things can wind up in
your stomach stein found a wide range of
foods
and not foods in the blob fish he
dissected
fish sea pens brittle stars hermit crabs
and anemone a plastic bag and also
lots of rocks their summer contents kind
of bear out
the fact that they're probably not too
bright
he also found octopus beaks the
cephalopods hard
indigestible jaws this means that one of
the world's flabbiest fishes has been
able to eat one of the sea's most
cunning predators
if you're surprised just think about the
blobfish's thick skin
what would be harder to grab in a fight
a sack of bones or a sack of jello
stein suspects it might be the latter if
the skin is loose perhaps the suckers
can't really get a good grip on it stein
found sucker marks across the blobfish's
body
a hint that the fish might have been in
some deep-sea fights
so while all of this jello might look a
little unconventional
well it seems to have served its purpose
the blobfish is perfectly suited to life
in the deep sea
where beauty standards are probably
quite different
after all well ugly is kind of in the
eye of the beholder
[Music]